-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy Award-winning actress
and comedian who you know
from her work on
"SNL," "Bridesmaids," and
the Netflix series "Big Mouth."
She stars in and
executive-produces "Loot,"
which premieres
on Apple TV+ tomorrow.
Please welcome back to the show
our good friend
Maya Rudolph, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Maya! How are you?
-Hiya, Maya.
-It's so nice to see you.
-It's nice to see you, Sethly.
-I know.
I know we've talked about it
before,
but when you started at "SNL,"
everybody --
a lot of the women on the cast
called you "Mayers."
-Yes.
-Like, "Mayers!"
Which is my last name,
and I thought it was very rude.
-Yeah. I mean,
I did have seniority,
so I feel like it's okay.
-You did have seniority.
I should have legally changed
my last name.
-I think you should have.
It was a sign.
-How are you?
-I'm great. How are you?
-I'm good.
Last time you were here,
we were talking about
your four beautiful children
and how much they were engaging
with your work.
Have they seen more
of your work?
Are they more familiar
with your output at this point?
-I mean, I still
don't think anyone wants to
watch "Big Mouth" because of me.
-Okay, gotcha.
-Because I think it's gross to
hear your mom talk about boners.
-Yeah. I think that's, like,
that's age-old.
-That's a boner deterrent.
-Yeah.
-I was like, "I know how
I won't get my kids
to think about boners.
I'll be a hormone monstress."
Yeah, so they don't --
-Do they watch old "SNLs"?
-They do, actually.
-Okay, that's good.
-Actually, you know what?
What was the one
that I just showed
Pearl the other day?
It was --
I think she was shocked.
It was, like, a true early-2000s
host, like, "Wait.
You knew that person?"
I was like, "Yeah.
Yeah, I was alive in 2002.
It was pretty cool."
-I've had it backfire on me
with my kids where, like,
my kids met Wiig, Kristen Wiig.
-Yeah.
-You knew which one I was
talking about.
-I was getting her confused
with the Cleveland Wiig we know.
There's so many Wiigs.
-With the double I's.
They're all, yeah, that, too.
That very common spelling,
with two I's next to each other.
But she played --
They met her and they liked her.
And I was like,
"Oh, you have to watch this."
And she played, like, a
Macy's Thanksgiving Day Parade
float that was, like,
really scary.
And I showed it to them,
and then they were like,
"We don't want to
see her anymore."
-They were like --
[ Laughter ]
-"We don't wanna see that lady.
Yeah, we didn't realize
what a bad vibe she was."
-"That's your friend?"
-Yeah.
-"Great friends, dad."
-Are your kids as musically
talented as you are?
-I think they have the gift
of music and they don't realize
how great they are, so they kind
of keep it to themselves.
But, yes,
I force them all to play,
to have, like, piano lessons.
-Do you want them --
-To start a band?
Yeah.
-Okay. Would that be the dream?
-Well, I have four kids, so,
like, during COVID, I was like,
"Guys, it would be great if
you played those drums."
Or like, "I mean,
there's a piano, a bass,
a guitar, and an amp in here.
Who knew?"
-Do you think you'd be
a really good band mom?
Would you be, like, in the wings
watching your family?
-I'd probably be like --
What's that
Goldie Hawn-Susan Sarandon
movie?
I'd be like --
-Oh, gosh, I don't know.
-They're both
wearing leather jackets
and, like, ripped T-shirts,
but they're like
in their late 40s.
They're like...
I'd be embarrassing.
-Oh, that's good.
Well, then
I also want it to happen.
-I would really like that,
just to be, like, a groupie.
Like, "Those are my kids!
They rock!"
Just, like, no bra.
-They're like, "Wait. Your mom
is the one without a bra
and the hormone monster?"
-"Your mom hit on me at
craft services."
-They -- Now, all your kids
were in "Licorice Pizza."
-Yeah.
-As were you.
-My husband's movie.
-How was that?
-That was actually
a magical thing,
because COVID happened,
lockdown happened,
and then Paul was told like,
"Okay, you can shoot now."
But my kids were not allowed
to go back to school.
So we were doing Zoom school.
And it was a scary time,
and no one was vaccinated.
And it provided this amazing
experience where my kids,
their friends,
their friends' parents,
my parents, my nanny --
we were all in it,
and so we were all around.
And so we had, like,
a little world.
Like, we were living
in the 1970s
in the San Fernando Valley
for like three months.
It was beautiful.
-That's great.
How did they take to
being directed by their father?
-I think it's helped.
-Oh!
-No, no. They loved it.
Like, it only made their worship
of their father stronger.
-Oh, that's really cool.
-They just think
he's such a stud and a cool guy.
-You also filmed "Disenchanted."
-Yes.
-This is you and Amy Adams.
You seem to be --
There seemed to be, like,
a slightly eviler vibe
to what you're doing here.
-Yeah. This is like the meat and
potatoes of character actors.
Like, you want to be the evil
villain in a Disney movie.
It's, like,
everything you could possibly --
It's drag.
I'm doing drag.
And it was so fun.
It was so much fun.
I had long nails
and I got to be nasty
and I got to
sing and dance and wear
really tight corsets
and beautiful gowns.
And Amy Adams is --
-So lovely.
-She's the greatest.
Plus, she's already
a magical human being,
and then, as Giselle,
it was like it was real,
like it was
a true princess come to life.
But it was so funny,
because, like, everything
about her is so beautiful.
It's like hanging out
with Cinderella.
And so everything about her
was, like, this beautiful
white carriage and her horses,
and they were so lovely.
And I realized
I had a carriage, too.
I had a black carriage.
And I had these big, beefy,
like, black horses.
And her horses --
My horses peed a lot.
-Yeah.
-And her horses never peed.
And we realized,
"Oh, those are female horses."
Mine were male.
-Uh-huh.
-They had the biggest [bleep]
I've ever seen.
And at one point,
I have to get out of
the carriage
and talk to her and greet her.
And she goes
to curtsy in front of me,
and it sounded like someone
threw a bucket of water
on the ground.
And I tried not to look,
because it was right behind me.
And it was going on for a while.
I'm like,
"How many buckets are they --
Don't they know we're rolling?"
And we kept going,
and then I looked back
and I saw some people doing
like, kind of church laughing.
They're, like, facing me.
The horse was still pissing.
It peed for so long.
Have you ever seen a horse pee?
-I don't think
at this level, no.
-Wow! Maybe it's because
it was an Irish horse.
It was very healthy.
-Yeah, very healthy.
I hope they keep that in.
-I think they will.
It sounds like
a Disney thing, right?
-We'll be right back with more
from Maya Rudolph, everybody!